Have you
ever cracked your knuckles and had someone
yell at you to stop because it causes arthritis?
25-54% of the world’s population cracks
their knuckles, men more so than women.
Does this mean up to 54% of us will get arthritis?
The short answer is no.
There are different types of arthritis and
no study has ever shown a link between cracking
your knuckles and it causing any type of arthritis.
Let’s talk about why and what is actually
causing the “cracking” noise when you
crack you’re knuckles.
The knuckles are the joints formed by the
bones in our fingers.
Each finger consists of three bones (phalanges).
They’re named based on where they are in
relation to the palm of your hand.
There’s the proximal phalange (closest to
the palm), the middle phalange, and the distal
phalange (farthest from the palm).
The first knuckle is called the metacarpophalangeal
joint (MCP).
(Say that after drinking 3 beers and watch
the laughter ensue!)
The second knuckle is the proximal inter-phalangeal
joint (PIP) and the last knuckle is the distal
inter-phalangeal joint (DIP).
The fingers, and thus the joints, are held
in place by ligaments and tendons.
There are no muscles in the fingers and movement
is controlled by forearm muscles pulling on
your finger tendons.
Your knuckles are also covered by a joint
capsule known as your synovial capsule.
There’s fluid within this capsule known
as synovial fluid.
This fluid provides the lubrication and nutrients
needed for the joint and surrounding bone.
This fluid also contains several gases (oxygen,
nitrogen and carbon dioxide).
When you crack your knuckles, you stretch
out the synovial capsule creating a negative
pressure within the joint.
This pulls the gasses out of the fluid in
the form of a bubble which bursts to create
the popping sound.
To crack the same knuckle again, you have
to wait for more gases to build up in the
synovial fluid.
There are over 100 different types of arthritis.
Generically, arthritis is simply inflammation
of your joints.
It can be caused by everything from autoimmune
problems (rheumatoid arthritis), bacterial
infections (nongonococcal bacterial arthritis),
to sexually transmitted diseases (gonococcal
arthritis).
In the case of cracking knuckles, the type
of arthritis often thought to be caused by
it is the most common, osteoarthritis.
Osteoarthritis can be a normal result of the
aging process.
It can also be caused by excessive wear and
tear on the joint.
The result is cartilage breaking down and
wearing away.
The bones can begin to rub together and sometimes
cause spurs to develop.
Pain, swelling, and stiffness are the most
common symptoms.
So does the constant “popping” of the
gases within the synovial fluid cause the
“excessive wear and tear” that can cause
osteoarthritis?
There have been several studies that looked
at this question, and none have shown that
habitual knuckle cracking causes wear and
tear.
One study looked at 300 patients over 45 years
old and found that among the worst knuckle
crackers there was no increase in the incidence
of arthritis.
They did find, however, that the more you
cracked, the lower your grip strength was
over time.
So the next time you feel like cracking your
knuckles, do so with the knowledge you won’t
get arthritis from it.
You might, however, have damage to your ligaments
and tendons that reduces your grip strength,
but hey, what vice doesn’t come with
a little risk!